welcome to safety blitz starring
two-time super bowl champ and rodney
harrison rodney hope everything is good
one man who it is not so good for right
now is drew brees i feel like as we go
into our five biggest takeaways we have
to start right there
five fractured ribs and a collapsed lung
here is drew brees and head coach sean
payton after a win they were still able
to pull out yesterday
you know we took a heavy shot in the
first half
um came in
uh as he came out in the second half he
felt
it was really impacting him you know so
i'm not you know specifically he'll get
a he'll get an mri and x-ray his back
felt sore
as he tried to throw he just came up to
me and said hey i don't feel like it's
uh
i'm capable of
of playing and so quickly we made the
switch i i i was not going to be able to
be effective
um
it had nothing to do with pain it was
simply just what my body was
going to be able to do or not be able to
do
[Music]
so here's the scoop he fractured three
ribs against the bucks two weeks ago and
then another two ribs against the 49ers
yesterday so that's five total fracked
ribs and then the collapse lung have you
ever heard of something like that rodney
he's really still in the game trying to
play through it
well first i got to ask you how many
ribs do you have
[Laughter]
i was counting them out before we came
on i'm guessing it's somewhere in the 20
range
really so i mean if i'm if i'm sean
payton the thing that i do i first of
all i sign a quarterback i sign a backup
quarterback i start jameis winston
that's the reason i brought him in for
him to be insurance policy this is a
five-year starter yeah he's thrown a lot
of interceptions last year he threw 33
interceptions but at the end of the day
he this is a guy last [ __ ] it threw for
over five thousand thousand yards he has
more experience than taysom hill you
continue to use taysom hill and spot
duty whether it's tight end full back
tailback let him come in sometimes and
run the rpos and things that they like
to do with him but at the end of the day
man you've got to start jameis winston
because of his experience jack
it seemed like jameis was going to sort
of step into the breeze role and that he
would be the the passing quarterback of
the offense and then taysom was
basically still just going to play take
some duty where he comes in and he runs
you know power running attack from the
quarterback position does all those
things play some tight end plays some
special teams it just didn't seem like
taysom's role was gonna change was that
your sense is is is jameis winston good
enough to carry the load of this offense
it seems like almost anybody that steps
into a sean payton offense playing
quarterback has success pretty fast
well i mean i think the key for him is
keeping it simple for james not going
into a situation where you're putting
pressure on him to throw the ball
consistently down the field like he had
to do in in tampa bay last year and also
think about it he's got so many weapons
at his disposal he's got michael thomas
back healthy emanuel sanders jared cook
alvin kamara who i think should be in
the mvp conversation so he has a lot of
weapons where he doesn't have to do
anything do i trust him no i don't trust
jameis winston for the life of me but
guess who i trust i trust sean payton i
think sean payton will get in his ear
and tell him you don't have to do
everything this is a completely
different offense we have a lot of
weapons we're not going to force you to
throw the ball down the field we want
you to protect the ball that's the
number one thing jack
it does feel like we're getting a little
bit of our answer though with regard to
taysom because when they you know
decided that they were gonna give him
the contract extension make sure that he
was gonna be a new orleans saint for
this season give him a little boost and
to pay all of those things a lot of
people thought that he would be the next
drew brees that he would step in and
instantly become you know the next
franchise quarterback of the new orleans
saints and i don't think that that's the
case now i really don't i think he does
everything that sean payton loves i
think he comes in he's tough you know
he's not afraid to run the ball hard
he's not afraid to make big plays on
special teams play tight end make plays
in the passing game he's everything that
sean payton loves but i don't think that
he's the next drew brees if he were
he would already be in that role i think
we would have seen him there on sunday
we did not see him there on sunday and
the amazing thing was when jameis
winston came into the game immediately
nobody's covering camara and he gets to
do the same thing that drew brees has
done so often just dump it down to alvin
kamara and let him go be the best player
on this offense and that was the exact
strategy that they adopted as soon as
brees left the game
yeah you look at taysom hill and i agree
with you he's not a polish passer he's
not a polished quarterback matter of
fact when he look when he's back there
in shotgun he looks uncomfortable he
doesn't really look comfortable so
you know
i agree with you 100 it's jameis it's
jameis opportunity and see what he can
do and then take some he'll continue to
use him as an athlete in different
positions whether it's tight end full
back let him come in and spot duty um
sean payton knows what he's been doing i
mean this guy this guy has been jameis
um taysom hill has been in the system
for a long time he knows what he's gonna
you know what he's capable of doing
well let's get to another quarterback
who has shown a lot of success from the
pocket and that quarterback is kyler
murray comes all the way down to the
hail mary yesterday they got to chuck it
up who were you and more impressed by on
that final play of the game the throw
and the scramble of kyler murray or
deandre hopkins stealing it from the
entire secondary
what it has to be i mean it has to be
kyla murray i mean yeah deandre hopkins
he went up over three guys and went up
and made a beautiful catch
but kyla murray to be able to escape the
way he did
roll to his left
flip his hips and throw across his body
50-something yards that was absolutely
incredible and deandre hopkins that's
the reason why they traded for you and
gave up so much and paid you the money
that they paid you because they believe
that you can make plays like that and
look at them you can't even stick this
guy with three guys he's so good but
yeah man it was just such so much of a
fun game to watch
it was and and really it wasn't like the
bill's defenders didn't do their job it
was just that deandre did his job so
perfectly that he was going to be the
only guy coming down with that football
but it was so amazing that kyler could
scramble really breaks the tackle just
to create enough space to be able to get
the throw off and then he's leaning
backwards his entire weight and momentum
is falling sort of back left and then to
be able to put that thing 55-60 yards in
the air easily with a little bit of air
under it with a little bit of that
skyscraper type ball that has a chance
to come down where deandre can go up and
get it was really just so impressive it
does make you wonder
hopkins his whole career has sort of
been lingering in the top five and you
know probably really disrespected much
of the time that he spent in the texans
in terms of never really in
consideration for the best receiver in
football people love to put a b or julio
or somebody else right ahead of him in
that conversation
should he be right there now though
should he be the best receiver in
football or at least in that
conversation in your mind's eye
i'm gonna answer your question and then
i'm gonna revert back to something yes
he should be in that conversation i
believe he's one two i believe it's
it's either him or dk metcalf i mean it
just depends on what you you know what
you like i mean it depends on your
flavor now if you're talking about a guy
that's intimidating the most
intimidating receiver in the national
football league is definitely dk metcalf
but when you look at the cardinals i
mean you look at you look at the
cardinals and you see colin murray
scrambling around and maybe he only has
20 yards at halftime but he puts so much
pressure on a defense where you have to
completely change your defense to try to
get one or two guys spying on them and
you know you look at the patriots last
last um last night they played a lot of
zone against lamar jackson and that's
what you have to do against kyler but he
was still effective a couple
russian touchdowns i think this kid is
tremendous he talked about you know this
team it's time for this team to really
take that next step and go to that next
level and i tell you he's trying to will
that team to do it
well let's hear from bill's head coach
sean mcdermott on how they maybe could
have played that kyler murray attack a
little bit differently throughout the
course of that game
was there anything that you think could
have been different other than the
outcome of the play in how it was
defended or could you have done any
better than that
they come i mean yeah of course
i mean
honestly could i have done any better of
course i could have done better yeah i
meant i meant in terms of the okay that
that's what i was yeah there's always
that's that's why i said what i said
that when i came in here the very first
question i said you're always as a coach
you always think about what we could
could have done differently that's the
very first thing i said
what what could i have done differently
what could we have done differently
right you asked the players the same
questions
we got great guys in this locker room
they're saying the same thing knock the
ball down you can't be interception
minded in that situation knock the ball
down right so at the end of the day give
them the credit they made a special play
and i'll tell you let me just say this
can i tell you yeah go ahead
how did i tell you how should you play
that
yep
i'll tell you this you know sean
mcdermott he you know when you're
playing in a situation like that i hate
when i see defenses on television
everybody just takes 20 30 yards they
sit back and they let these run wide
receivers if you're one of these nickels
one of these underneath guys you see
five of them come up here and jam and
slow these guys down
because if you slow these guys down and
now all of a sudden it takes them longer
to get down the field and also
edmonds is your middle linebacker he's
6'5 235 40 pounds put him deep put him
at the goal line so anything that's
thrown he can knock it down but leslie
frazier's defensive coordinator and you
have to be a lot more aggressive you
asked coach dungy he pointed this the
same thing point out that i'm making
right now get up to those wide receivers
jam them slow them down and now you're
buying time for your defensive line to
get after calamari
it's interesting so a lot of what you
just mentioned was before the ball's in
actually in the air so when it is in the
air though and it's really just hopkins
and about three or four bills defenders
how do they teach you or coach you about
what you're supposed to do because it
did seem like a lot of the bills were
trying to catch the ball were
intercepted minded at that point in the
game should they have been pulling at
his arms should they have been going for
the ball what specifically should they
have been trying to do to hopkins is
he's trying to pull in the hail mary to
go win the game
well just from the years of my
experience you're taught to go down
there and basically get in front of the
wide receiver just depending on you know
who you are are you the safety are you
the corner and and how the coaches um
teaching it and box them out and when
the ball is thrown
go down with the ball push the ball down
don't try to catch it don't try to pad
your stats and that's exactly what they
tried to do not one guy i didn't see one
guy try to knock the ball down that's
very disappointing you think about all
the work that you put in on monday
tuesday wednesday thursday your body
studying film studying different
checks and adjustments and it comes down
to a play like this this is devastating
for a team especially a team like
buffalo that's been struggling at times
running a football struggling at times
playing defense struggling at times
stopping the run very disappointing
because this should have never happened
and sean mcdermott knows it
especially when it's coming off a
game-winning drive that they just had
put together and josh allen's been
playing so tough and was so good down
the stretch and stefan diggs has the
game winner who's really been dominant
ever since he got to buffalo and so they
had won the game they had done
everything possible to win the game and
even had a chance to get kyler on the
ground in the backfield before he gets
the hail mary off but that's what's so
hard about playing kyle murray i mean
throughout the game he just broke their
back so many times with his legs and you
mentioned two of them when he gets down
around the goal line and he pulls that
read option i mean he sometimes is
crossing the goal line before half the
defenders even know that he pulled that
thing out he is so fast and so dynamic
when he gets down into the red zone and
so often you just see arizona end up
with seven instead of three solely
because of the legs of kyler murray and
that's really what won on this game
yesterday too
yeah buffalo did a really good job of
you know defensively of preventing the
big play and then all of a sudden toward
the end of the game you wait to the
basically the last play of the game and
you give up and then you want who you
have back there to be in that position
you got your dave is white your pro bowl
corner you have a pro bowl safety you
matter of fact both your safeties micah
hyde and jordan poyer these are some of
the best safeties in the national
football league and i didn't see anyone
boxing out i didn't see anyone trying to
swat the ball down and like i said your
middle linebacker is six five like this
is so simple like
put him on the goal line and dare anyone
to throw the ball at him he's six five
and he just
jump up and throw the ball it's just
losses like this like i talked about all
the hard work and effort that you put in
can really affect the team we'll see
what happens to buffalo here in the next
couple weeks
there it is because we'll talk all week
now about how good kyler murray is and
how good the cardinals is and really
that was the bill's conversation it was
just
stolen from him by the kyler murray hail
mary right there at the end okay the
rams there's another team beat seattle
seattle now a lot of mistakes a lot of
turnovers a lot of ugliness stuff that
we're just not used to seeing from
seattle but on the ram side of things
this was about as perfect of a jared
golf game as you're going to find he was
just comfortable efficient putting the
ball perfectly on target throughout the
course of the game and they got the win
it's amazing because you saw jared goff
and sometimes i make fun of him because
i call him country club because you know
i mean when he's back there and he's
comfortable and he's got all this
beautiful protection he's going to pick
you apart but if you put pressure on
them and you hit them you make them
uncomfortable then we see a different
jared goff and yesterday they had the
run game going the offensive line did a
great job although they lost andrew
wentworth who is going to be a huge lost
veteran presence
leadership toughness everything
but
it's just amazing to me when they're
running the football everything comes
off the play action pass the bootlegs
and let me tell you something man when
you're watching that tape i want you to
watch robert woods everything that he
does from running the football trying to
run linebackers over from blocking um
just catching the ball the energy that
he plays with man i just i fell in love
with robert woods i mean he is just all
over the place and every time you put on
film he does the same thing nothing ever
lets up in his the speed of the game in
which he plays
i was going to ask you that because when
you look at their team on paper there's
really not a dominant wide receiver
obviously brandon cooks was there
recently he's no longer with the team so
there's not one name that you go oh
that's their deandre hopkins or that's
their number one that's their julio
that's their whoever the case may be
they just don't have a name that pops
out as a number one wide receiver so is
robert woods starting to become that for
this team or is the power of this
offense that they don't really have a
number one and he spreads the ball over
the field cooper cup higby the tight end
about three different running backs they
have in the mix now is that the power of
this team or are you seeing woods
starting to become the number one option
i think i think they have i think robert
woods is the number one option i think
cooper cup is a phenomenal number two i
think their run game is excellent you
talked about tyler hickby but i'm
talking about gerald um everett he is
athletic he's fast they both complement
each other so they have two tight ends
that are really good athletic tight ends
they can catch they have three really
good running backs they have a good
offensive line they have a solid
quarterback i mean they have everything
you want and they have a mastermind call
into plays and defensively they've
gotten better and just think about when
they move jalen ramsey to the star spot
or the nickel spot and it just seems
like all the other guys kind of just
started making plays and interceptions
they're tackling better because when
they played against buffalo
maybe a month ago i was complaining
about the lack of physicality the missed
tackles and all those different things
and it just seems like jalen ramsey has
come in and really kind of just brought
that secondary together and really taken
him to the next level
and rodney you mentioned that defense
the defense has been playing very well
let's hear from sean mcvay on his d
after the win
unbelievable job by our defense you know
darius williams with two unbelievably
big picks for us
uh second half the one after the
turnover offensively to be able to get
that play this guy shows up in a big way
i thought jalen ramsey was outstanding
throughout the course of the day didn't
see a lot of action from some of the
guys that he was over the top of and
just our defense as a whole i mean you
just can't say enough about what they've
consistently done doing it against an
offense that's arguably
producing at the highest level in the
league right now
so there you go there's mcveigh on his d
rams are rolling let's get to another
defensive performance that i know you
loved and it came in prime time sunday
night football bill belichick got
another look at lamar jackson and this
left you going he's still the best
belichick still the best coach in all of
football why rodney
you know i've heard coach belichick so
many times this year talk about being
out coached outplayed and not prepared
and i understand the patriots haven't
had a lot of practice but a lot of teams
haven't had a lot of practice but i
thought last night was a masterful job
because he used the weather just like
when we used to play against the colts
and all these other teams these
california teams that came in and really
used it to his advantage but he went
back to his roots what are the patriots
roots even when tom brady was there was
physicality having tough smart guys that
play well under pressure and it always
started in the trenches whether it was
the offense line or defensive line and
they controlled the offensive line i
mean they absolutely did a wonderful job
and damien harris like what other number
the number 37 should he be wearing this
dude is tough he's physical he runs with
a lot of energy and between him and rex
burkhead what more do you want from the
from from from the running backs i mean
james white is excellent out of the
backfield but those two guys are very
versatile too so like when i watch him
this is what we've been expecting from
the patriots we've been expecting this
tough physical team that doesn't make a
lot of mistakes we expect a level of
accuracy from from camby short
intermediate passes and i thought
belichick did his best coaching job
since the seattle game um last night
yeah we've seen flashes of that offense
having success i mean i even think back
to the seattle game that they had sunday
night football that was when the offense
was really out that was this new patriot
offense and it's two teams talking about
baltimore talking about new england that
have a similar question to answer is
that if you don't have a prolific
passing game
can you make a deep playoff push can you
go win playoff games and maybe the
answer is yes
when the weather's like it was on sunday
night football it plays into the hands
of both of those teams really in the way
that they want to attack you they want
to run their quarterbacks they want to
get the power running game going i mean
probably the best pass that we saw all
night rodney came from a wide receiver
when you're talking about the new
england patriots so do you think it's
possible to make this deep playoff push
without a passing game that seems like
it's anywhere even near the top 10 of
the nfl
see the only thing that makes me say no
is when i think about kansas city when i
think about say pittsburgh i mean they
can put up points they can pass the ball
and but the thing about kansas city
that's different from pittsburgh they
can run the ball if they decide they
have to they'll be there if they're
forced in a situation where they have to
run the football i believe kansas city
can straight up run the football with
those backs that they have with the
offensive line that they have and just
the amount of pressure that that offense
and patrick mahomes and all those
weapons put on you you know it's going
to force you to keep two safeties back
and once he sees two safeties back he's
handling the ball off to clyde edwards
hillaire
and you mentioned kansas city you
mentioned pittsburgh those are two teams
that just so wealthy with playmakers it
just seems like they can score every
time they touch the football another
offense that's starting to look like
that too the bucks which is surprising
to say after they just got smoked by new
orleans it's a bounce-back performance
and it started to look like you know
everyone sort of is dreaming up this
bucks team as a super bowl contender
this was the first time i sort of felt
it saw it antonio brown looked like a b
this looked like the old a b mike evans
looked like you know the player we had
come to expect gronk even looked healthy
for you know certain points of that game
certain points he doesn't look quite as
healthy but they have so many guys that
they can work the ball to in a big day
for ronald jones running the football
too
yeah that was the key and you think
about tom brady if if they want to have
success they have to be able to run the
football because it takes pressure off
tom brady when tom brady once again he's
very similar to jared goff he's back
there nice clean pocket he's gonna pick
you apart he's gonna oh mike evans over
there one-on-one oh antonio brown he's
gonna pick you apart but if you put
pressure on him you hit him it's it's
gonna be completely different so um i
like what they did running the ball and
trying to reestablish that physicality
at the line of scrimmage and that's what
they're gonna have to do because
sometimes brady's 40 some years old he's
going to be off and he may not have that
chemistry with his wide receivers but if
you're not if you're not clicking with
your wide receivers can you line up and
run the football and that's something
that we're going to find out here in the
next month of the season
and the thing that's kind of funny too
just watching a b play is that it seems
like about half the time he doesn't even
really know what the play is what the
call is and so he'll be communicating
with the other wide receivers who are
standing next to him like just trying to
figure out like what route do you want
me to right here slant go like you name
it and then they kind of whisper it to
him and you can watch it happen and then
he runs around and he's wide open so
it's like he's still learning the
offense it's only his second week
playing with the bucks
once they get this thing flowing down
the stretch is this going to be the
antonio brown that we're all used to
seeing one of the best wide receivers in
the whole league
i don't think so i don't think you're
going to see one of the best wide
receivers because you know why because
he's not going to be the featured guy
he's got to deal with look at those
names chris godwin mike evan mike evans
rob gronkowski the backs out of the
backfield cameron breit all the other um
scotty and all those guys that he has to
deal with i mean he's got so many guys
so i think antonio in order for him to
really be that breakout superstar that
we're expecting i think he has to be the
number one receiver
but on this team he could be a really
good quality receiver and let me tell
you this is what is going to come down
to
jack in the passing game
if these guys these receivers chris
godwin and all the guys that i name if
they're okay with one another getting
and and them not being the man
then they're gonna be okay but if
jealousy creeps in or a little envy oh
man why does he get in so many passes
i've been here you know i'm making all
the money that's when problems happen so
hopefully they can continue to just go
smooth but if they start getting jealous
of one another it's gonna be a mess down
there
i almost feel like they're gonna have to
figure out a way to get along because
it's kind of what the top of the league
is becoming right now it reminds me of
the nba some where it's like the top of
the league is just so talented
pittsburgh casey now the bucks too
people are just loading up on playmakers
and it seems like if you're going to
make a deep playoff push that you're
going to have to be one of those teams
that can go score 40 points when we get
into the playoffs and the way that the
bucks are built i mean you just look at
these receivers godown is an awesome out
route runner and really got that going
yesterday a b
same situation scotty miller you
mentioned and then size gronk mike evans
breit they all have the ability to win
with size and so when when brady can
stand back there and just go got a
one-on-one with gronk here i got a
one-on-one with evans here and i got a b
working in the middle over with the slot
i mean i don't know how
one of those guys is going to be open
every single play and the amount of
targets that they've given a b early
lends me to believe and they missed him
for about a 66 67 yard bomb for a
touchdown too tom just overthrew him a
little bit early on in that game so this
could have been a way bigger antonio
brown day and then the whole world would
have been talking about a b i think he
has one of those huge 140 150 yard
couple touchdown games coming up and i
i'm going to guess it's going to be
coming soon
yeah and and you know what you don't
mind as a coach or ev a teammate that he
would have those type of games but he i
don't believe he's going to have those
type of games every single week they're
very difficult to have especially when
you have so much talent so you know a
lot of times you can have six or seven
passes and then looking forward to the
following week but you may only get two
catches you still have to keep your
attitude positive you still have to
support your other wide receivers and
make sure that there's no bitterness and
all those different things but tom brady
is so good at making sure that
everybody's on the same page but
one of the things that really took
the teams that i played on um to
championships was just no one cared
about who got the credit no one cared we
didn't care who got the commercials even
though tom got all the commercials we
didn't care who got the pretty girls
anything like that it was just about
football congratulating and supporting
one another jack
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports